avec 10 à 15% de leur achalandage
habituel autobus et métros sont presque
vides 1 montréal
mais tôt ou tard les usagers reviendront
en grand nombre la règle des deux
maîtres deviendra alors presque
impossible à respecter enfin trouver des
manières de rendre sauf viable dans le
transport collectif
parce que la distanciation social de 2 m
dans le transport collectif on a fait
des calculs petite règle de trois pour
nos calculs et que ça nous prendrait
lumier d'autobus et 800 rame de métro
mais oubliez l'idée la stm n'a même pas
2000 autobus et 100 rames de métro
jusqu'ici 46 de ses employés ont
contracté le virus
les chauffeurs s'inquiète de ce que
réservent les prochaines semaines ce
qu'on demande de santé publique que
c'est d'imposer le port de masques
c'est ce que l'allemagne vient
d'annoncer pour sa capitale berlin le
même scénario est à prévoir en france
pendant qu aux états unis au moins cet
état dans new york et pose déjà le
masque dans tous les lieux publics en
réponse un journaliste anglophone
aujourd'hui horacio arruda cette avancée
pour le québec
pippo good thing that will be inc
les usagers du transport en commun
devront mettre masque dit il surtout
s'ils ne peuvent pas respecter les deux
mètres c'est sûr que des masques va
protéger notre gorge et notre nez de
petites gouttelettes qui pourrait
atterrir mais il ya quand même nos yeux
et nos mains qui sont d'autres vecteurs
de transmission
bref ajoute caroline kw h thann
continuez de vous laver les mains
masques ou pas dans les rues de montréal
l'idée de se protéger le visage fait son
chemin
je vous vois valable et mes distances
raisonnables avec le port du masque faut
pas exagérer non plus déjà là on prend
dont les maîtres peuvent confectionner
de massy en arena de servir sow c'est
sûr que j'aurais le masque c'est un
point important parce que pour l'obliger
encore faut-il en avoir assez ou s'en
remettre aux masques artisanaux qu'on
verra de plus en plus dans nos rues ici
j'en sais pas c'est que l'outil radio
canada montréal